[موسيقى]
مساء الخير بعد مرور عام على انطلاق الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه هناك عشرات الاسئله
المهمه على المستوى السياسي والعسكري
والاقتصادي تبحث عن اجابات واحد من هذه
الاسئله هو لماذا فشلت الولايات المتحده
وحلفاؤها في حشد كل دول العالم ضد العدوان
الروسي على اوكرانيا لماذا يتعاطف كثير من
دول العالم مع المعتدي وليس الضحيه
محاوله الاجابه على هذا السؤال تقتدي ان
نفهم الصوره الكبيره والصوره الكبيره
بتقول لنا انه ما عن دلاع الحرب في 22
فبراير 2022 انقسم العالم الى ثلاثه
معسكرات غير متساويه معسكر صغير
عدد دول خمس دول تقريبا او سته دول بتؤيد
العدوان الروسي على اوكرانيا وهذا المعسكر
بيضم دول مثل سوريا وبيلاروس وكوريا
الشماليه كوبا ويمكن ان تضيف اليهم ايران
ومعسكر ثاني كبير وقوي وغني يضم نحو 40
دوله على راسها الولايات المتحده كل دول
حلف شمال الاطلسي ومعهم حلفاء امريكا
والغرب اليابان كوريا الجنوبيه تايوان
استراليا نيوزلان لسنغافوره اذا اردت اسما
مختصرا لهذا التحالف يمكن ان تسميه بالغرب
السياسي لانه يضم دول واقعه في الغرب
الجغرافي
مثل دول اوروبا بالاضافه الى حلفائهم في
اسيا اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه وتايوان
وسنغافوره الى اخره
المعسكر ده لم يكتفي فقط بفرض حزم متواليه
من العقوبات على روسيا عشر حزم من
العقوبات الكبيره جدا على الروس ولكنه
منخرط ايضا
في
دعم سياسي ودبلوماسي
وعسكري كبير جدا لاوكرانيا في حربها ضد
الروس المعسكر الثالث وهو الاكبر على
الاطلاق وبيضم معظم دول العالم الاخرى
ودول موجوده في اسيا
وافريقيا ومنها طبعا كل دول منطقه الشرق
الاوسط والعالم العربي وامريكا الجنوبيه
واللاتينيه
اذا اردت اسما واحدا لهذا المعسكر الكبير
يمكن ان تسميه كما يسمى الان في الادبيات
الغربيه بالجنوب العالمي او الجلوبل ساوث
والقلوب هو الاسم اللي بات يطلق على ما
كان يعرف قديما بالعالم النامي
كتير من هذه الدول او معظم هذه الدول ان
لم يكن كلها اعلن الحياد ماذا يعني الحياه
كثير منها يرفض ادانه او بعضها يرفض ادانت
روسيا في مجلس الامن وفي الامم المتحده
لكن معظمها يرفض العدوان الروسي على
اوكرانيا ويعتبره عدوانا غير شرعي لكنه
يرفض الانضمام الى حمله العقوبات
الامريكيه على روسيا نعم يدين الغزو
الروسي لاوكرانيا لكنه يرى
ان هذا الغزو ما كان له ان يحدث لولا
الاستفزاز الغربي للروس باصرارهم على
توسيع حلف شمال الاطلسي شرقا ليهدد الامن
القومي الروسي ولا يتعاطفون كثيرا مع
اوكرانيا على اعتبار انها وقعت في فخ
الثقه في الغرب والانضمام اليهم مستفزه
الروس والنتيجه طبعا سوف تكون على انقاذ
الاوكران والاوكرانيين
حياه هذا المعسكر الجنوب العالمي بيمثل
تحدي كبير للولايات المتحده اللي سعت على
مدار ال 12 شهرا الماضيه انه تقنع اكبر
عدد من هذه الدول بالتخلي عن حيادهم
والانضمام الى المعسكر الغربي لخنق وعزل
الروس حتى هذه اللحظه لم ينجحوا بشكل
ملحوظ او بشكل مؤثر ان يغيروا مواقف الدول
معظم الدول في هذا المعسكر طب ايه دوافع
الدول
بقطع النظر يعني عن رؤيتهم لتوصيف الصراع
مجموعه من الاسباب السبب الاولاني اللي
بيدفعهم للالتزام الحياد وعمد وعدم
الانضمام للحمله الامريكيه ضد الروس
واحد علاقتهم القويه بروسيا هذه علاقات
قويه
تجاريه
سياسيه ودبلوماسيه مع الروس وروسيا دوله
كبيره الغرب بيميل الى التهوين والتقليل
من شان روسيا وبيختصرها في رقم واحد اللي
هو رقم
بيقول ان دي دوله الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
لها حوالي واحد ونصف تريليون دولار
وبالتالي لا يجب ان تكون مؤثره على
الاقتصاد العالمي
دول الجنوب لا ترى الامر على هذا النحو
وتدرك ان الروس تصدر لهذه الدول صادرات
بالغه التاثير للسلع استراتيجيه يصعب ان
تحصل عليها من غير روسيا وان حصلت عليها
لم تحصل عليها بسهوله وبهذا السعر روسيا
لا تصدر لدول العالم الاخرى
السيجار الكوبي ولا الجبن السويسري دي
بتصدر لهم السلاح والطاقه والغذاء
هذا اولا ثم ان روسيا على علاقه ومع
حليفتها الصين على علاقه
بتعتبر علاقه احترام متبادل لهذه الدول
يعني حين تتعاون روسيا وتصير مع هذه الدول
فهي لا تعاملها بنفس الازدراء والتعالي
اللي بتعمله الولايات المتحده حتى ما
حلفائها
اثنين ان الدول ان كثير من دول الجنوب
العالمي تضررت من هذه الحرب بشده في اكثر
من خمسين دوله وفقا لتقديرات صندوق النقد
الدولي
عاجزه عن ان هي تسدد ديونها بسبب تابع
عيات الحرب والعقوبات التي فرضها الغرب
على الروس لكنها تدرك ان الضرر سوف يكون
اكبر اذا انضمت الى العقوبات التي تفرضها
امريكا وحلفائها على روسيا هي شاهدت ما
حدث للاتحاد الاوروبي الاتحاد الاوروبي
مثلا فرض حذرا على الغاز الروسي ولما اراد
ان يبحث عن بدائل وجدها في عده مصادر اخرى
على راسها الامريكان الذين باعوا الغاز
لحلفائهم الاوروبيين باربعه وخمسه اضعاف
الامر اللي دفع الرئيس الفرنسي ان يقول
عنان للامريكان
ما هكذا يجب ان تكون الصداقه
مثال من دول المنطقه دول المنطقه اللي بيض
وادارته وحلفائهم زي البريطانيين بيضغطوا
عليهم لينضموا الى المعسكر الغربي ضد
الروس حاولوا اقناعهم بانه
يترك تعاونهم مع الروس على كل المستويات
ومنهم التعاون من خلال
اللي بيستفيدوا منه وانه هم يقوموا بزياده
انتاج البترول ماذا يحدث حين هذه الانتاج
البترول سوف تنخفض اسعاره فتستقر الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه في امريكا واوروبا وهذا امر
جيد ويتضرر الروس بشده لان عوائدهم من
البترول والغاز سوف تقل لكن الدول العربيه
والدول المنتجه عربيه او غير عربيه قالوا
للامريكان لكن هذا سوف يضرونا ارتفاع
اسعار البترول والغاز امر مفيد لنا وهو
المصدر الرئيسي الاقتصادنا يعني انتم
بتطالبونا بان احنا ننضم اليكم على حساب
مصالحنا ورفضوا
لكن السببين دول مش هم
فقط الاسباب اللي دعت دول الجنوب العالمي
في العالم العربي وغير العربي الا ينضموا
الى المعسكر
الغربي في حربه على روسيا في سبب ثالث هو
مهم جدا هذا السبب يمكن اختصاره سوء
اختيار امريكا للشعار اللي ارادت ان تحشر
به باقي دول العالم في حربها على روسيا ما
هو الشعار امريكا خطبت عن غفله
واستفزاز دول العالم الاخرى بانه يجب ان
تنضموا الينا ضد روسيا
انقادا للنظام الدولي القائم على القواعد
بالانجليزي
الثلاث كلمات دول انقاذ النظام الدولي او
النظام الدولي القائم على القواعد كان
كافيا جدا لصرف كل دول العالم في الجنوب
العالمي عن المعسكر الامريكي ليه
امريكا وهي بتحاول ان تسوق هذا الشعار عن
غفله كبيره وبشكل مستفز ربما دون ان تدري
منطقها كالتالي
يا دول العالم انضم الينا لانه انضمامكم
الينا ينقذ هذا النظام العالمي القائم على
القواعد وما هو النظام القائم على القواعد
النظام العالمي اللي تاسس او اللي بيحكم
العالم منذ انتهاء الحرب العالميه التانيه
1945 والى الان النظام اللي امريكا ساهمت
بالجزء الاكبر في صياغته وهي على راسه
وان النظام ده ساغ مجموعه من القواعد
والاعراف بتنفذها مجموعه من المؤسسات
الدوليه في القلب منها الامم المتحده
ومؤسسات اخرى وطبعا في قلب الامم المتحده
مجلس الامن ثم مؤسسات اخرى زي المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه منظمه التجاره العالميه
البنك الدولي صندوق النقد الى اخره
وان هذا النظام كان من مزاياه انه حافظ
الامن والاستقرار والسلم في العالم بعد
حربين عالميتين الاولى والثانيه وكان في
اوجه نجاحه في القاره الاوروبيه التي لم
تشهد اي حروب من سنه 45 الى الان افتح
قوسين حروب البلقان او يغزلفيا السابقه ما
كانتش تعتبر حروب داخليه نتيجه تفكك
السابقه لكن مفيش حرب من دوله ضد دوله
اخرى
وبالتالي عليكم ان طهره تهرعوا دول العالم
لانقاذ هذا النظام اللي بيتم تقويضه
بالسكوت على عدوان روسيا على دوله ذات
سياده من بين قواعد النظام العالمي القائم
على القواعد هو احترام الحدود القائمه
احترام سياده الدول عدم تغيير هذه الحدود
بالقوه
النظام ده صحيح حفظ السلام بمعنى انه حاله
دون اندلاع حرب عالميه بين الدول الكبيره
ولو ان ديت فيها اعتبارات اخرى منها توازن
القوه وكان في اوجه نجاحه في اوروبا صحيح
لكنه لم ينجح بنفس
المعدل او بنفس
النجاح في دول الجنوب العالمي هذه الدول
عانت من حروب واضطرابات ضخمه جدا في ظل
النظام العالمي القائم على القواعد
هذا اولا فهم لم يستفيدوا من هذا النظام
بقدر استفاده اوروبا والدول الكبيره اثنين
وهو الاهم انه العالم كله شايف حاله نفاق
فج جدا من الجانب الامريكي يرون بوضوح ان
النظام المبني على قواعد هي قواعد كتبتها
امريكا وهي تلتزم بها فقط حين يغضب
مصالحها وتقوم امريكا نفسها بخرق هذه
القواعد لما بتتعارض مع مصالحها اكثر من
خرق هذه القواعد المكتوبه هي الولايات
المتحده
وبعض حلفائها وعلى راسهم اسرائيل طبعا
اللي هي عندها رقم قياسي في خرق كل
القواعد والقوانين الدوليه بحمايه امريكيه
دعونا من اسرائيل الان العالم اللي امريكا
بتحاول حشده للدفاع عن النظام العالمي
القائم على القواعد
لاحظ وشاهد امريكا مش تاريخيا ده في
السنوات الاخيره وهي تخرق هذا النظام بشكل
متكرر يعني مثلا ان الرئيس الامريكي
السابق ترامب كان يحمل احتقار شديد لهذا
النظام وقام
بخرق عده مرات
على سبيل المثال في يونيو 2018 قرر دون
سابق انذار الخروج من مجلس حقوق الانسان
التابع للامم المتحده ليه لان المجلس تجرا
وانتقد اسرائيل عده مرات متواليه
ونيكي هيلي اللي هي كانت مندوبه امريكا في
المجلس في ذلك الوقت وبالمناسبه هي بتسعى
الان لخوض الانتخابات عن الحزب الجمهوري
قالت سبب غريب جدا هذا مجلس يركز اكثر من
اللازم على اسرائيل اكثر مما اكثر من
تركيزه على ايران او كوريا الشماليه او
كوبا ما يعني ان هذا مهجلس المسيس وخرجوا
2020 في ظل اداره ترامب خرجت اداره ترامب
من منظمه الصحه في اوجه حربها على كوفيد
19 لان المنظمه لا تعمل وفقا للتصورات
الامريكيه في نفس العام سبتمبر 2020 كانت
الاستفزاز الاكبر لامريكا والخرق الاكبر
لهذا النظام الدولي المبني على القواعد
لان امريكا قررت فرض عقوبات على كبار
مسؤولي المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لانها
تجرات
وقررت ان تفتح تحقيق في احتمال تورط جنود
امريكان في جرائم حرب اثناء احتلالهم
لافغانستان افتح قوسين اداره بايدن
الحاليه بتحاول ان تساعد المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه في جمع ادله على تورط جنود روس
ومسؤولين روس في جرائم حرب في اوكرانيا
طبعا ممكن جدا حد يقول الامثله التلاته
كلهم مرتبطين بفتره رامب وترامب كان حالها
استثنائيه بيتبرا منها الرئيس الحالي ممكن
بس اولا الرئيس ترامب لم يكن زرعا شيطانيا
كان رئيس امريكا وانتهت ولايته ليس في
التاريخ البعيد ده في يناير 2021
ولما خسر الانتخابات في 2020 حصل على اكتر
من 75 مليون صوت ما يعني ان هناك تيار
كبير جدا يؤيده داخل امريكا وهذا التيار
قد ياتي به رئيسا مره اخرى في 2024
ومع ذلك دعونا من ترامب كاملا لا خرق
النظام الدولي المكتوب على القواعد التي
تحاول امريكا انقاذه الان وحجز دول العالم
لانقاذه بعزل روسيا لم يكن قاصرا على بيض
الحالي مثلا ما زال مصرا على خرق القانون
الدولي والنظام الدولي المبني على القواعد
ترامب
في السيل او الاوزيون اللي عمله والارضاء
حليفه اسرائيل
قرر انه
يعترف بضم اسرائيل لمرتفعات الجولان
السوريه وهو ضم غير شرعي تماما لانها
اراضي سوريه
الرئيس بايدن
بعد حوالي اربع سنوات على هذا القرار او
اكثر من ثلاث سنوات ما زالت تعترف امريكا
في ولايته بان الجولان السوريه هي اراد
اسرائيليه افتح قوسين دم اسرائيل للكولان
لا يختلف شيء عن محاوله روسيا ضم اراضي
اوكرانيه بالقوه بل بالعكس الموقف الروسي
افضل ليه افضل لان روسيا لما حاولت تضم
اراضي من اوكرانيا حاولت ان تجد مبررات
وفقا للقانون والنظام الدولي المبني على
القواعد يعني قالت انه وفق الحق تقرير
المصير
في اوكرانيا معظمهم من اصل روسي قرروا
الانفصال عن الدوله الاوكرانيه واجروا
استفتاءات هذه الاستفتاءات
قررت بموجبه هذه الاقليات ان هي تنضم
لروسيا الاتحاديه هل هذا كلام مقنع لمعظم
دول العالم لا هل هذا كلام صحيح شكيك فيه
كما تريد لكن لها استندت الى حجج حتى وان
لم تكن مقنعه الاسرائيليين ما قدموش اي
حاجه سوى انه عدوان على اراد السوريين
والاستيلاء على ارض استخدمت ضدها سنه 1967
طبعا المثال الكبير جدا اللي يعني لا يجب
ان احنا نبذل جهد كبير في ذكره انه
الادارات الامريكيه المتعاقبه تجاهلت
القانون الدولي المبني على القواعد في
الحاله الفلسطينيه الرئيس ابو مازن محمود
عباس في حوار مؤخر له كان واضح لحضراتكم
رابطه
جمع عدد القرارات التي اصدرتها الامم
المتحده منذ سنه 47 والى الان وقال انهم
بلغوا 754 قرارا تجاهلتهم اسرائيل كلها
بدعم امريكي
مساله ليست قاصره على لابيض ولا ترامب
والامثله كثيره جدا في دول المنطقه وخارج
دول المنطقه يعني مثلا
الغزو الروسي
الغزو الامريكي للعراق سنه 2003 بقطع
النظر عن انه غزو همجي ودمر بلد ذات سياده
وادرب المنطقه بالكامل لكن ما يهمنا انه
كان خرقا واضحا للنظام الدولي المبني على
القواعد لانه لم يكن بتفويض لا من مجلس
الامن ولا من الامم المتحده وكوفي عنان
اللي هو الامين العام
للامم المتحده في حوار مع البي بي سي في
15 سبتمبر 2004 قال ان هذه الحرب التي
قراتها الولايات المتحده غير شرعيه غير
قانونيا لا تتوافق مع ميثاق الامم المتحده
التي تدافع عنه امريكا كتير من الناس
الكلام ده تم في عهد جورج الابن كثير من
الناس من خصوم معمر القذافي ابتهجوا لسقوط
نظامه واعداء فرحوا في
سقوطه ومقتله حقهم هذا امر يخصهم لكن ما
يهمني
ان تغيير النظام في ليبيا في 2011 تم
بالمخالفه للنظام العالمي المبني على
القواعد بمباركه الامريكيه مجلس الامن كان
فوض اعضائه في فقط حمايه المدنيين
الليبيين من بطش معمر القذافي وجيشه اخذوا
التفويض وتجاوزوه
وسلحوا المعارضه
وحيدوا السلاح الليبي وتجاوزوا ذلك بتغيير
النظام وتصفيه الرئيس معمر القذافي نفسه
خارج اطار القانون الدولي وده كان واحد من
الخلافات العنيفه بين الغرب وبين روسيا
وايضا معها الصين انتم خدعتونا ودي قصه
يطول شرحها
الامثله كثيره جدا وليست قاصره على دول
المنطقه
في نوفمبر 2022
والامريكان لسبب يبدو انهم يعيشون منفصلين
عن الواقع ارادوا ان يفهموا من دبلوماسيين
من ذوي السمعه الدوليه لماذا تصطف كثير من
دول الجنوب العالمي مع روسيا اللي هي
معتد واضح على ضحيه واضحه فاستضافوا في
معهد كوينزي وهو سنك تانك مهم في امريكا
وله موقع
رصين في السياسه الدوليه اسمه
يمكنكم ان تتابعوه ان اردتم
استضفوا مين
استضافوا وزير خارجيه برازيل سابق اللي هو
السيد اموريم واستضافوا كيشور محبوبان
دبلوماسي سنغافوري ومعروف يعني خارج حتى
سنغافوره للمهتمين بالشان الدولي
واستضافوا وزيره خارجيه
جنوب افريقيا الحاليه
خلاصه اللالوه انا واضح لحضراتكم رابط هذه
الندوه المهمه ان سنوات القياده الامريكيه
للعالم قد انتهت وانه لا احد ياسف عليها
لانها كانت مليئه بالنفاق والمعايير
المزدوجه بل والتنمر على الدول الاخرى
ولهذا فان مساحيها مساعي امريكا
لحشد دول العالم ضد الصين وروسيا
اللذان يسعيان لتاسيس نظام عالمي جديد لا
تكتب فيه القواعد في واشنطن
فابرز مثال على هذا الفشل فشل امريكا في
حشد دول العالم لادانه الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا
مريم وزير خارجيه البرازيل السابق لهم
انتم بتتكلموا على نظام عالمي قائب على
القواعد لكن القواعد اللي انا شفتها
بتتغير طوال الوقت وما زالت تتغير بحيث
تحابيكم انتم فقط
محبوباني قال لهم انه انتم مقسمين العالم
لابيض واسود هو عالم متعدد الالوان مش
بالضروره كل دول العالم في الجنوب العالمي
تفكر كما تفكرون وتفعل ما تريدون وزيره
خارجيه جنوب افريقيا كانت الاكثر قسوه على
الامريكان وقالت لهم نظام المبني على
القواعد التي تريدون ان ننتفض لحمايته
يعمل حين تريدون ويتعطل تريدون يعمل حين
يتعلق الامر باوكرانيا لكنه يتعطل حين
يتعلق الامر بفلسطين وقالت لهم انه
بقدر ما يستحق شعب اوكرانيا ارضه وحريته
فان شعب فلسطين يستحق ارضه وحريته ايضا
وكانت نفس هذه الوزيره والدبلوماسيه
الصلبه ننادي بندور كانت في اغسطس من 22
يعني بعد الحرب بعده اشهر وفي مؤتمر جمعها
مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي اتهمت
الامريكان بالاستعلاء والتنمر على
الافارقه وقالت لهم مللنا من اسلوبكم اما
في تعاملكم مع الافريقي اما ان تفعلوا ذلك
والا الويل والصبور وعظائم الامور
الخلاصه انه كتير من دول الجنوب
لا تتعاطف مع الروس حبا في الروس ولا
تتعاطف معهم من باب يعني تبلد الاحساس
تجاه الشعب الاوكراني هو فقط تعاطف مع
اولا رغبه الروس في الثوره على نظام عالمي
تكتبه امريكا ولا تريد ان تلتزم به
بالمناسبه قبل ما اخرج من النقطه ديت
ما حدش بيقول ان عملته روسيا ليس عدوانا
على اوكرانيا ولكن في تفاهم شبه يعني
اجماع على ان ما تطلبه روسيا هو مطلب
مفهوم ومفهوم على الاقل وفقا للمعايير
الامريكيه ودي نقطه قلتها مرات متعدده
عن عقيده كارتر التي تخول الولايات
المتحده استخدام القوه المسلحه ضد اي دوله
اجنبيه تفكر في التواجد المضر للمصالح
الامريكيه في منطقه الخليج سواء في الجانب
الايراني او الجانب العربي لانها منطقه
حيويه للمصالح الامريكيه
الولايات المتحده كادت تدفع العالم الى
حرب عالميه ثالثه في اكتوبر 62 لان دوله
ذات سياده وهي كوبا قررت ان تحمي نفسها
بالاستعانه بقواعد عسكريه لدوله كبيره
الاتحاد السوفيتي هددت عده مرات كوبا بغزو
امريكي ارادت ان تحمي نفسها بان هي تستضيف
قواعد عسكريه سوفيتيه وفعالتها في غفله من
الامريكان لما الامريكان افاقوا وجدوا ان
هذا يمثل خطرا شديدا عليهم ان دوله على
بعد حوالي 150 كيلو من حدودها
من شواطئها تحتضن قواعد عسكريه نوويه
للسوفيت فحاصرت الجزيره وكادت الحرب
العالميه الثالثه تحدث امريكا لم تقل ان
كوبا دوله ذات سياده يحق لا ان تختار ما
تشاء من الحلفاء اذكركم ان السوفيتي لما
وضعوا السلاح هناك كان في محاوله للضغط
على امريكا
لتزيل اسلحتها الموجوده في تركيا في
الستينات وتركيا طبعا كانت على حدود
الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق اذا فالدول
الجنوب العالمي هي متعاطفه مع المنطق
الروسي لانه المنطق اللي امريكا اتبعته
لكن طرفه دول العالم الاخرى ان تتبعوا
تعاطفهم قليل مع السلطه في اوكرانيا لانها
اوقعت نفسها في فخ
يعني
الصراع بين القوى الكبرى بينما هذه الدول
ترى ان هذا صراع بين قوه كبرى لا ناقه لنا
فيه ولا جمل هذه ليست حربنا واخيرا ان كل
الاسباب السابقه ديت مش بس بتقول لنا ليه
دول كثيره تعاطفت مع المعتدي وليس مع
الضحيه ولكنها توضح لنا ايضا مساله مهمه
تستحق ان نناقشها في حلقه مقبله هو الاثار
بعيده المدى لهذه الحرب على المستوى
العالمي كتير من المحللين بيعتقدوا ان
امريكا مستفيد خالص من هذه الحرب مستفيدين
من الاستنزاف روسيا مستفيدين
من حرمان الصين من قوه الروس الحاليه
مستفيدين من مبيعاتهم للسلاح والغاز
والحبوب انما ما هو محل نظر ما هو استفاده
امريكا من النظام العالمي
اللي بدا يتضعضع وتضعف شرعيته في اعين
وقلوب كثير من الدول العالم وفي القلب
منها دول الجنوب العالمي التي ترى ان هذا
النظام بيت رهينه للمصالح الامريكيه فقط
يعمل حين تريد امريكا ويتعطل حين
يتعارض مع المصالح الامريكيه وهذه قصه
تستحق ان نناقشها في حلقه مقبله باذن الله
اشكركم والى اللقاء